énorme iq
excellente performance à l'école
mais tu as abandonné la
drogue les
délits mineurs
n'ont jamais eu de
travail qui t'a mis sur une certaine voie
mais tu n'as pas besoin de rester dessus
qui tu es l'homme qui t'a fait libérer
je n'ai jamais rencontré de tailleur auparavant mais je
sais  tu n'es pas un viens avec moi
qu'est-ce que tu vois
je vois un jeune homme avec du potentiel
tirer le crochet sur ta gauche
oh oui
très gentil
qu'est-ce que ça fait électrocuter tu ne
sois pas ridicule
c'est une grenade à main tais-
toi c'est malade
nous  sont une
agence de renseignement internationale indépendante
opérant au plus haut niveau de
discrétion
les
agents kingsman sont les nouveaux chevaliers que
vous êtes sur le point de vous lancer dans l'
entretien d'embauche le plus dangereux au monde
bien désolé pour le garçon il
trouvera cela humiliant il est autant
kingsman  matériel comme n'importe lequel d'entre eux
nous sommes là pour améliorer vos compétences
vous tester pour
limiter résoudre des problèmes sous pression
comme quoi faire quand l'un de votre groupe
n'a pas de parachute
des
manières intéressantes faites-le
mec
j'ai du mal à vous comprendre  les gens
parfois vous parlez tous si drôle
et qu'en est-il de lui ce qui le rend si
spécial